[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend das friedensnobelpreis
komitee hat in diesem jahr die
pressefreiheit aufs schild gehoben
die ja keineswegs nur journalisten
betrifft den starken ohne freie medien
sind auch alle anderen bürgerinnen und
bürger nicht frei der friedensnobelpreis
wird einer journalistin und einem
journalisten verliehen die unter
bedingungen arbeiten die man sich als
kolleginnen lieber nicht ausmalen möchte
maria ritter von den philippinen
betreibt unter lebensgefahr ein online
nachrichten total auf dem sie präsident
dotierte und seine todesschwadronen
kritisiert und enthüllt welche ausmaße
seinen krieg gegen das eigene volk hat
wird bedroht und von der regierung
regelmäßig mit gerichtsverfahren
überzogen der russische journalist
dimitrij muratow chefredakteur der
nowaja gaseta der letzten kritischen
zeitung kann russland er hat bereits
sechs seiner mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter betrauert sie wurden
ermordet oder starben unter verdächtigen
umständen etwa durch vergiftung die
journalistin sterblichkeit in russland
ist generell auffällig hoch für das
stellt uns die beiden preisträger vor
die auszeichnung gelte nicht ihm sagt
der frisch gekürte
friedensnobelpreisträger und
chefredakteur der nowaja gaseta
dieser preis gehört denjenigen die von
uns gegangen sind und den brillanten
jungen menschen die jetzt den dritten
stock unserer redaktion bevölkern
wo sie heute feiern gedachten sie erst
gestern anna politkowskaja deren
berichte aus tschetschenien ihr mächtige
feinde einbrachte
der mord an der journalistin ist gestern
verjährt ohne dass die hintergründe
aufgeklärt wurden
mit dieser risiken macht maschinerie
geheimpolizei agenten haben sie den
verantwortlichen nach 15 jahren immer
noch nicht gefunden das heißt es ist
kein zufall man kann mit journalisten
machen was man will der staat wird den
mörder decken
im vergangenen jahrzehnt wurden in
russland 23 medienschaffende getötet auf
den philippinen waren es 17 hier kämpft
die zweite preisträgerin mit den mitteln
des journalismus gegen machtmissbrauch
maria resser mitbegründerin einer
investigativen nachrichtenseite vom
regime verfolgt mehrfach behaftet ist
sie gerade auf kaution frei
journalisten ihre arbeit machen
journalismus ist kein verbrechen sagt
dressler und journalismus gefährlich sei
da werde er wohl am dringendsten
gebraucht dem autoritären staatschef
dotierte weiß die philippinerin
menschenrechtsverletzungen nacht
fakten sind sehr langweilig aber
trotzdem beginnt doch alles mit einer
gemeinsamen realität die von fakten
definiert wird
fake news ein weltweites problem und
diejenigen die gegen desinformationen
ankämpfen unter beschuss rund um den
globus
der journalismus ist in gefahr
demokratien werden durch desinformation
sich gerüchte durch hassrede geschwächt
der nobelpreis wird sehr nützlich sein
um alle aufzufordern sich für diese
wichtige und zentrale gesellschaftliche
funktion den journalismus einzusetzen
boot und
dimitrij muratow war ja gaseta ist die
letzte unabhängige zeitung russlands im
märz wird eine ätzende flüssigkeit vor
dem redaktionsgebäude versprüht allen
bedrohungen zum trotz setzt sich morath
unermüdlich für die rechte kritischer
medien in russland ein deren arbeit der
kreml mit verschärften gesetzen immer
weiter einschränkt
heute ist einer der glücklichsten tage
unseres lebens er hebt hervor wie
journalisten in russland gegen zensur
kämpfen diesem überlebenskampf
es stellt sich heraus dass die welt
nicht an den grenzen der russischen
föderation endet sondern das manchmal
echte hilfe es über die grenze schafft
so die osmanische der friedensnobelpreis
in diesem jahr eine würdigung der
bedeutung von presse und
meinungsfreiheit für die freiheit
insgesamt überall auf der welt
pressefreiheit lässt sich ja nicht nur
mit klassischen instrumenten beschneiden
wie zensur oder einschüchterung auf
einer reise in bolivien da sagte mir mal
der chefredakteur eines
regierungskritischen blattes der seinen
posten hatte aufgeben müssen früher
haben sie uns nur gedroht inzwischen
sind sie smarter sie kaufen uns einfach
die bolivianische methode ist weltweit
sehr verbreitet es gibt sie auch in der
eu in einigen osteuropäischen ländern
gehören die großen medien leuten aus dem
regierungsumfeld britische blätter
werden hingegen finanziell ausgeblutet
dazu gehört auch staatliche anzeigen nur
in medien zu buchen die der regierung
genehm sind um eine sogenannte inseraten
politik geht es auch bei der aktuellen
regierungskrise in österreich die mit
geld einfluss auf boulevardblätter
genommen wurde und woher das geld kam
wie sich diese staatsaffäre heute weiter
zuspitzte berichtet wolf christian
ulrich
kommt die neuwahl oder nicht das ist die
frage die sich österreich am abend
stellte der kanzler vor die presse tritt
doch kurz hält sich immer noch für
kanzlertauglich
gleichzeitig möchten wir aber auch
festhalten dass wir als team der
volkspartei in der regierung
handlungsfähig und vor allem auch
handlungswillig sind die koalitionäre
lauern aufeinander wie boxer die auf den
ersten angriff warten und der erste
schlag kam heute morgen von den grünen
ein politisches ultimatum in aller
deutlichkeit es ist ganz klar dass so
jemand nicht mehr am 2
und selbstverständlich hat die svp hier
auch eine verantwortung eine untadelige
person zu nominieren offensichtlich
weigert sich die svp eine solche
unterjährige person bereit zu stellen
und deshalb sprechen wir mit den anderen
parteien am mittag waren wieder neue
jets aus den ermittlungsakten der
staatsanwaltschaft aufgetaucht es wird
immer klarer wie die vp mit steuergeld
wahlkampf gemacht haben soll indem sie
offenbar in der zeitung österreich vp
freundliche artikel und umfragen unter
bringen ließ verschleiert bezahlt aus
dem finanz mysterium was für die grünen
zunehmend unerträglich wird versuchen
mächtige ovp männer auszusetzen
ganz ehrlich ich habe diese 104 seid
nicht gelesen da bin ich nicht dazu
gekommen und das zweite das gilt für
jeden mensch die unschuldsvermutung was
in der vp für ärger sorgen dürfte
nachrichten wie diese in denen kurz
einen prominenten parteifreund einem
zitat arsch nennt sie werfen nämlich die
frage auf was über andere partei granden
noch alles gesagt wurde und das jetzt
als kurz die svp geschlossen hinter sich
braucht
kurz stellung in der övp beruht darauf
dass diese keinen plan b und noch keine
alternative hat kurz hofft selbst wenn
er abberufen wird auf schnelle neuwahlen
da dann ist er der logische
spitzenkandidat aber hinter den kulissen
nehmen sicher zweifel zu am abend strich
bundespräsident van der bellen zu seinem
land und zwischen den zeilen sehr
deutlich in richtung kanzleramt was wir
aber klar sehen ist einmal mehr ein
sittenbild dass der demokratie nicht gut
tut wir hören einen ton der
respektlosigkeit gegenüber personen
gegenüber institutionen ich habe andere
erwartungen an das verhalten von
politisch verantwortlichen die
machtmaschine um kurz hat offensichtlich
überdreht der kanzler verspricht weitere
gespräche doch die anderen parteien
wollen nicht mehr mit ihm der kanzler
ist allein seine regierung steht am
abgrund
man selbst schaut in abgründe darüber
wollen wir mit einem bekannten
österreichischen journalisten sprechen
mit florian klenk sein wochenblatt
falter recherchiert und enthüllt in
diesem bereich auch wird vielen jahren
gute namen florian klenk
guten abend das ist wenn man sich diese
chatprotokolle die ihnen ja alle
vorliegen das sind massen aber das was
sie bisher öffentlich geworden dass man
sich das an guckt also man wundert sich
als außenstehender so doch über die
tonlage einerseits so gut los die lehr
und andererseits aber auch zum teil fast
schon kindliche ist es irgendwie
befremdlich geht ihnen das
ja in österreich spricht in österreich
spricht man nicht mehr von götz zitat
sondern vom kurz zitat der scherz
beiseite was es da sich offenbart sind
drei dinge auf der einen seite dieser
rüde ton dieser umgangston der so gar
nicht passt zu dem credo von sebastian
kurz das andere nicht anpassen will auf
der zweiten ebene sehen wir auf einer
politischen ebene die versuche der övp
die zeitungen zu kaufen eine
boulevardzeitung eine sehr
einflussreiche pulver zeitung mit ins
raten zu kaufen und es gibt in den
strafrechtlichen aspekt nämlich dass die
zeitungsmacher beschuldigt werden der
bestechung indem sie nämlich dem
sebastian kurz und der öbb und
maßgeblichen beamten im
finanzministerium
die möglichkeit eingeräumt haben also
den vorteil gewährt haben die
redaktionelle berichte berichterstattung
einzugreifen und dafür ein amtsgeschäft
bekommen haben nämlich regierungsrat in
der höhe von 1,2 millionen diese riefen
uns hier in österreich im bereich der
schwerkriminalität diese
regierungsinserate die machen großen
teil des budgets aus dass
boulevardzeitung aber auch andere
zeitungen haben sie hatten ja früher
denke ich auch regierungsinserate bis
sie in den zonen wurden oder ihr
habt die regierungsinserate werden nach
gutsherrenart vergeben der falter zum
beispiel bekommt keine
regierungsinserate das ist die
schattenseite oder die zweite seite
dieser medienpolitik nämlich dass man
die willfährigen medien mit millionen
überschüttet die kritischen medien aber
entzieht erst vor kurzem hat ein
prominenter medien geschäftsführer
beklagt dass alle inserate entzogen
wurden vom finanzministerium weil man
die övp kritisiert hat es werden hier
die privaten interessen der partei
mit öffentlichen mitteln betrieben und
das liegt jetzt offen wie die detektiv
fotos in einer in einer ferienwohnung
erstmals schwarz auf weiß lesen kann
dass das was wir immer vermutet haben
und das was wir immer wieder sondern
gerochen haben sich tatsächlich ereignet
wie geht es denn jetzt ihre einschätzung
nach weiter mit dieser affäre und mit
herrn kurz
naja er kurz begreift jetzt langsam dass
sich sein leben maßgeblich ändern wird
die grünen wollen mit ihm nicht mehr
koalieren vielleicht noch mitläufer wer
aber nicht mehr mit ihm als
bundeskanzler die öbb begreift langsam
dass er die partei ist die sich auf
sebastian kurz fokussiert hat sie ist
eine fein partei geworden sie ist keine
bürgerbewegung mehr und langsam über das
wochenende wird die verbindung
realisieren dass sebastian kurzen nicht
mehr bundeskanzler sein wird die große
frage ist kommt zu neuwahlen bei
neuwahlen glauben alle dass sebastian
kurz wieder gewinnen kann ich bin mir da
nicht mehr so sicher nicht nur weil es
seine pressesprecher keine handys mehr
haben und journalisten nicht mehr
einfach so anrufen können scherz
beiseite aber es wird einfach dieser
druck die in diese message controller
hatte nicht mehr funktionieren die
medien haben sich abgewandt von ihm auch
die konservativen medien auch die medien
die ihnen jetzt jahrelang bejubelt haben
drehen sich weg und sagen er soll
zurücktreten aber einmal dem letzten
nach der letzten aufführung stich von
ibiza video als die koalition zerbrach
da hatte er bei den neuwahlen dann ja
fulminant gewonnen also sicher kann man
sich da wahrscheinlich doch nicht sein
oder da war allerdings der war
allerdings heinz christian strache die
person die der meinung war dass die
journalisten die größten hürden sind die
man bezahlen kann für eigene zwecke
jetzt sebastian kurz zu sagen diese
rolle von strache geschlüpft und und mit
ihm seine engsten vertrauten und es kann
sich in österreich zumindest in den
medien in der öffentlichkeit derzeit
niemand vorstellen dass er ernsthaft
noch einen koalitionspartner findet er
hat jetzt alle drei koalitionspartner
gehabt hatte die spd hatte die grünen er
hat die fpö und jeweils ist die sind die
parteien haben sich von ihm abgewandt
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
er weiter bundeskanzler sein wird das
ist eine erkenntnis die bei ihm langsam
sickern wird erst sehr schnell sehr hoch
gestiegen war das shooting star er war
der star auch in europa und jetzt steht
er da als jemand diesen chats man lesen
kann
und blickt hinter die hinterbühne seiner
politik er hat sich seinen wahlerfolg
nicht durch durch wahlkampf
kostenüberschreitungen in millionenhöhe
erschwindelt sondern eigentlich auch
durch manipulation der öffentlichen
meinung hat viel druck gemacht der
funktionäre hat druck gemacht auf die
öffentliche meinung und die beliebtheit
der hatte dadurch auch verstärkt und die
leute kommen langsam darauf hier zu sein
wirklich tickt die einschätzung von
florian klängen chefredakteur von der
wochenzeitung falter danke ihnen nach
österreich sie sind gerade bei einer
galaveranstaltung wo sie auch diese zeit
vorgetragen haben und wir werden hier in
deutschland interesse beobachten wie das
in österreich weiter geben danke schön
ja fragt sich ob eine so manipulative
boy group die ihre konservative partei
regelrecht kaperte ein geeignetes
vorbild ist für andere konservative auf
sinnsuche was zum konservativen ja
eigentlich gar nicht passt die
institutionen verachtung die mit dem
populismus einhergeht etwa gegenüber
recht und justiz
empfohlen wurde unter der
nationalkonservativen pis partei
zunächst die politische unabhängigkeit
des verfassungsgerichts beschnitten und
das wurden dort die eigenen leute
platziert jetzt kam die nächste
eskalationsstufe
ebendieses verfassungsgericht stellt nun
das rechtsverhältnis zur europäischen
union grundsätzlich in frage was in
brüssel wiederum mittlerweile die
gegenfrage provoziert wenn man ein
gemeinsames europäisches recht nicht
anerkennen will man dann überhaupt noch
eu mitglied bleiben anne gellinek
bericht
am tag nach dem urteil sind die
polnischen zeitungen genauso gespalten
wie das land der poleksic hat begonnen
fürchtet die liberale gazeta wyborcza
die konservative gazeta polska schreibt
dagegen polen ist unabhängig und
demokratisch ausrufezeichen ausdruck der
unabhängigkeit ist wohl das urteil des
polnischen verfassungsgerichts das
schockwellen nach brüssel schickt teile
von eu recht sein mit der polnischen
verfassung nicht vereinbar polen stellt
sich damit gegen regeln die es beim
eu-beitritt freiwillig akzeptiert hatte
der national konservative polnische
justizminister feiert das urteil
ausdrücklich so war schon das ist eine
sehr wichtige entscheidung in einer
situation in der eu behörden unterstützt
von berlin und anderen europäischen
hauptstädten kohlen juristisch angreifen
sie behandeln polen wie eine quasi
kolonie die gesetze von einer behörde
akzeptieren soll die polnische bürger
nicht kontrollieren können europa war
vorbereitet auf dieses urteil und ist
trotzdem von seiner wucht überrascht
aber muss sagen ganz klar dass diese
regierung in polen mit dem feuer spielt
das heißt dass in einem gewissen moment
nicht nur richtig sondern auch politisch
das zu einem bruch kommen kann wenn es
nicht den geringsten respekt für
gemeinsame regeln und europas freiheiten
gibt dann kann es natürlich auch keine
gelder geben um polens wirtschaft zu
beleben das ist doch klar
tatsächlich hält die eu-kommission 36
milliarden euro hilfen aus dem corona
topf zurück unsicher wie lange noch
bislang hatte von der leyen die
konfrontation mit polen eher gescheut
jetzt lässt sie ihren justizkommissar
sagen dass man durchgreifen werde
wir werden alle mittel nutzen die in
unserer macht stehen und schauen was das
wirksamste instrument
geld kürzen fordert auch das
europaparlament doch einfach ist das
nicht auf dem mammutgipfel im juli 2020
hatten die osteuropäischen
regierungschefs in den verhandlungen zum
eu haushalt durchgesetzt dass der neue
rechtsstaats mechanismus nur eingesetzt
werden kann wenn es um korruption und
veruntreuung von eu geldern geht nicht
aber bei der aushöhlung des
rechtsstaates
ich bin nicht sicher dass der
rechtsstaat mechanismus hier genau das
richtige werkzeug ist aber dann geht es
natürlich darum dass jetzt sofort
möglichst der fluss von eu-geldern nach
polen gestoppt wird sobald dieses dieses
urteil rechtskräftig ist es ist eine
machtprobe eine kampfansage ein urteil
das die eu herausfordert und auf dass
die europäer so recht noch keine antwort
haben
und jetzt erstmal nachrichten aus
deutschland von 1 12 die
kultusministerin und minister der länder
haben das ziel bekräftigt dass es in
diesem schuljahr nicht wieder zu
schulschließungen kommen soll in einem
beschluss der kultusministerkonferenz
heißt dass es sei unerlässlich die
schulen offen zu halten und den
präsenzunterricht dauerhaft zu sichern
die regelmäßigen testungen für
schülerinnen und schüler könnten bis auf
weiteres fortgeführt werden zu den
aktuellen corona zahlen das robert koch
institut meldet zehn 1429 neuinfektionen
innerhalb eines tages das sind 311 mehr
als vor einer woche in den 24 stunden
kamen 86 todesfälle hinzu die sieben
tage incidents ist leicht gestiegen auf
63,8
das verteidigungsministerium lässt wegen
des verdachts rechtsextremistischer
vorfälle gegen mitglieder des
wachbataillons der bundeswehr ermitteln
es geht auch um vorwürfe von übergriffig
keiten und sexualisierter gewalt wie ein
ministeriumssprecher in berlin mitteilte
die wehrbeauftragte hügel sagte nach
einem besuch des wachbataillons bisher
gebe es keine bestätigung einer
verfestigten rechtsextremen gruppe
innerhalb des wachbataillons wichtig
seien nun schnelle aufklärung und
sanktionen nach
langem hin und her hat der bundesrat den
neuen bußgeldkatalog
abgesegnet ein ziel radfahrer und
fußgänger sollen besser geschützt werden
wer innerorts mit elf bis 15 kilometer
pro stunde zu viel geblitzt wird zahlt
statt 25 künftig 50 euro geh und radwege
zu parken kostet statt bis zu 35 künftig
bis zu 100 euro neu zum schutz von
radfahrern müssen lkw in
schrittgeschwindigkeit
rechtsabbiegen andernfalls sind 70 euro
fällig
der sogenannte islamische staat hat sich
zu dem anschlag auf eine moschee im
norden afghanistans bekannt dabei seien
mindestens 43 menschen getötet und mehr
als 140 verletzt worden das teilte die
staatliche nachrichtenagentur mit in
einer nachricht dass die es hieß es ein
selbstmordattentäter habe in der moschee
während des freitagsgebets eine
sprengstoffweste gezündet immer wieder
verübt der mit den radikal
islamistischen taliban verfeindete es
anschläge auf einrichtungen der
schiitischen minderheit
die eu innenminister beraten heute über
den umgang mit flüchtlingen
das thema wird die europäische union
weiter beschäftigen und weiter für
konflikte sorgen denn es gibt ja auch
weiterhin keinen gemeinsamen plan und
kein gemeinsames handeln dafür offenbar
wildwuchs und rechtsbruch an einigen
grenzen dazu gehören so genannte push
back bei denen geflüchtete gewaltsam
zurück geprügelt werden berichte darüber
gibt es von der kroatisch bosnischen
grenze der griechisch-türkischen grenze
und aus dem grenzgebiet zwischen polen
und belarus gunnar krüger beginnt seine
berichte ich hallo wo mitten im wald der
grenzschutz dahinter drehverbot ein zdf
team begleitet polnischer aktivisten die
flüchtlingen helfen
wir haben keinen zugang zu dieser
sperrzone denn dort gilt der
ausnahmezustand
diese iraker kamen durch sie flohen im
flugzeug über dubai und belarus
wir nahmen ein taxi zur grenze und
gingen rüber da ein polnischer
grenzschützer finden uns ab und schickte
uns direkt zurück
das wäre ein push back und verboten wenn
sie sagen ich will asyl in polen der
zettel wird von nutzen sein wenn der
grenzschutz kommt denn von 9000 die im
september kamen schickte polen viele
zurück ohne anhörung das sei auch
rechtens denn meistens sei es so dass
keine der familien keiner der
erwachsenen will internationalen schutz
in polen alle wollen ihren antrag in
deutschland stellen die
zweifel an dieser erklärung reichen bis
in die spitzen der eu denn in der
sperrzone sind keine beamten der
grenzschutzagentur frontex keine
unabhängigen journalist verlange von
polen dass es medien in die sperrzone
lässt nur das gewährleistet transparenz
und zusammenarbeit
der fall zeigt einmal mehr die eu muss
sich ehrlich machen was bedeutet eine
starke außengrenze zwölf staaten denken
dabei auch an mehr stacheldraht von
lettland über polen bis griechenland
ich habe nichts dagegen wenn
mitgliedstaaten zäune bauen wollen aber
dafür geld zu nutzen das ist keine gute
idee
wir wollen dass die eu mehr nach außen
tut dass sie die außengrenzen schützt
und dass sie die zurückschickt die kein
recht auf schutz halt
grenzen schützen aber ohne gewalt da
sind alle einig staatliche schläger die
flüchtlinge misshandeln ein recherchen
netzwerk prangert kroatien an das
eingesteht
experten haben untersucht was passiert
ist und sie bestätigen dass polizisten
in dieser ereignisse verwickelt waren
jetzt gibt es eine untersuchung
in polen nehmen derweil grenzschützer
die iraker mit in die sperrzone diesmal
ist dokumentiert dass sie um asyl bitten
doch ob das eu-mitglied das eu recht
einhält lässt sich dort nicht überprüfen
und jetzt nochmal heinz mit wirtschaft
die stark gestiegenen energiepreise
bleiben eines der wichtigen themen für
die wirtschaft es gibt eine reihe von
erklärungen für die teuerung aber war
der reha erst mal die frage worauf
müssen sich die verbraucher einstellen
und darauf dass die energiepreise für
eine weile so hoch wohl bleiben werden
fachleute rechnen damit dass sie sich
erst in drei jahren wieder auf vor
corinna niveau einpendeln ja und auch
die eu energiekommissar in bereitet
verbraucher schon auf einen teuren
winter vor die energiepreise explodieren
gas ist innerhalb von einem jahr um 75
prozent teurer geworden öl sogar um 100
prozent beides also so teuer wie seit
jahren nicht die ursachen sind
vielfältig der weltweite energiehunger
aus industrie und wirtschaft nach den
einschränkungen in der korona pandemie
geringe gasvorräte weil der vergangene
winter ungewöhnlich kalt war und wenig
wind gab es in diesem jahr auch noch all
das treibt die preise das ist dabei
besonders wichtig denn das wird nicht
nur zum heizen verwendet sondern auch
zur stromerzeugung und der wird dann
eben auch zwangsläufig teurer das ist
ein problem für verbraucher aber auch
für unternehmen einige vor allem die
chemie-branche drosselten ihre
produktion weil es sich nicht rechnet
kommt ein strenger winter könnte sich
die situation noch verschärfen ökonomen
warnen schon vor einer energiekrise die
die konjunktur belasten könnte das thema
beschäftigt ganz europa beim eu-gipfel
in rund zwei wochen wird man nach
lösungen suchen valerie haller vielen
dank
unter dem dach der industriestaaten
organisation oecd haben sich 136 staaten
auf details einer globalen steuer reform
geeinigt die länder stünden für mehr als
90 prozent der weltweiten
wirtschaftskraft so die oecd
vorgesehen sei unter anderem eine
mindeststeuer von 15 für große konzerne
die regelung solle ab 2023 gelten
bei dem erdbeben gestern in japan in
tokio und umgebung sind nach neuen
meldungen mindestens 30 menschen
verletzt worden das beben der stärke 5,9
brachte gebäude ins wanken der zug und u
bahnbetrieb war vorübergehend
beeinträchtigt wasserleitungen platz in
einigen haushalten fiel der strom aus
japan ist eines der am stärksten
erdbeben gefährdeten länder der welt
finanziell war die hamburger
elbphilharmonie ja bekanntlich ein
desaster
jetzt wo sie da ist sind die hamburger
auch stolz auf ihr neues wahrzeichen
auch münchen plant seit längerem ein
neues konzerthaus das mit sicherheit
auch weit mehr als die 400 millionen
kosten wird die anfangs genannt wurden
und außerdem muss noch die alte
philharmonie am gasteig saniert werden
bis dahin stehen die münchner
philharmoniker in einem ausweichquartier
die neue isa philharmonie die heute
abend feierlich eröffnet wurde ist also
eigentlich nur eine zwischenlösung
allerdings eine mit viel charme und nach
barbara lux bericht denkt man
unwillkürlich vielleicht sollten öfter
mal provisorien geplant werden sie
könnten sich als dauerhaft erweisen
dieser abend setzt akzente
ein vollbesetzter neustart der
konzertkultur
der glückliche dirigent kleidet den
klang der neuen isaf- philharmonie heute
schon mal in wuchtige worte
[Musik]
da ist keinerlei kälte oder kühler
empfang
transparent ist noch so ein wort das
wichtigste wir müssen nicht mit aller
macht unser kraft vollstes spiel spielen
um gehört zu werden
diese neue isa philharmonie grenzt an
ein wunder ein mitten in der pandemie
hochgezogener konzertsaal für die
münchner philharmoniker in rekordzeit
gebaut und mit 40 millionen euro und
fassbar günstig
[Musik]
eigentlich nur ein ausweichquartier weil
der alte saal saniert wird aber das hier
ist vielmehr die hülle nicht so wichtig
alle kraft dient der musik wir haben
eine kostbare violinen gebaut und einen
einfachen sicheren geigenkasten der
wetterschutz bietet der schallschutz
bietet aber der tatsächlich auch als
zweckbau zu erkennen ist und das passt
ja auch ganz gut in dieses industrielle
werks fertigen
dort rund um den konzertsaal entsteht
gerade ein wildes nebeneinander ateliers
autowerkstätten handwerk design
schmieden ein urbaner kultur platz mit
einer mission die elitäre hochkultur
soll zurück auf den boden zu den
menschen ins leben
[Musik]
ob das jetzt volkskunst hoch kunst wie
es die sollte sich alles immer schön
vermengen
so erklingt classic in der autowerkstatt
und bald auch free jazz in der
bibliothek alles spielt ineinander diese
unterschiedlichen blicke auf die welt
vom reifenhändler letzten endes bis zum
intendanten das finde ich als sehr
bereichernd
in all das passt er wunderbar hinein
yasuhisa toyota
der weltweit wohl beste akustiker hat
den feinen klang der isa philharmonie
gestaltet auch ihm geht es um dialog
symmetrien um gemeinsame schwingungen
[Musik]
es geht darum eine intime beziehung
herzustellen nicht nur zwischen musikern
und zuschauern sondern auch innerhalb
des gesamten publikums
und so hinterlässt dieser abend heute
zwei gute botschaften was glänzt muss
nicht teuer sein und irgendwie gehört am
ende doch alles zusammen
[Musik]
das war es von uns gleich geht s mit der
heute show weiter und um 0.15 gibt es
dann unser heute schon ein update mit
christina von ungern sternberg auf
wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das beständige
hoch über russland ist immer noch
vorhanden uns ja verändert sich kaum und
im süden also richtung mittelmeer über
der balkanregion dreht sich hier dieses
tief weiterhin und sorgt für viel regen
bei uns gab es im norden deutschlands
nebel aber auch im süden nach norden hat
er sich er aufgelöst als in den
südlichen landesteilen schauen wir in
die nacht und da ist es in der osthälfte
größten teils aufgelockert ganz im
westen sind die wolken etwas dichter
ansonsten bildet sich nebel vor allem in
der nähe von gewässern oder das bei
temperaturen von 1 grad in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen und 8 grad zum beispiel
am niederrhein morgen vormittag vielfach
nebel zum beispiel nach norden in der
lässt allmählich nach oder auch in den
östlichen mittelgebirgen verschwindet er
ja und im süden bleibt ein bisschen
länger ansonsten gibt es viel
sonnenschein in der mitte und zum
nachmittag fast überall sondern nur noch
vereinzelt nebel ja und einige harmlose
wolken und das bei höchsten temperaturen
von 19 grad ganz im westen deutschlands
und elf grad an den alpen generell ist
es nach osten hin ein wenig kühler als
in den westlichen landesteil schauen wir
auf die nächsten tage am sonntag nach
nebelauflösung sonniges wetter
überwiegend 10 bis 17 grad die höchsten
werte am montag kommt von nordwesten
neuer regen auf ansonsten im süden aber
größtenteils trocken bei 10 bis 16 grad
und dienstag ziemlich durchwachsenes
wetter damit ein schöner abend